what are we having a look at today i'm
going to introduce to you
another new piece of logical
machinery that's going to help us think
through all the different
statements and implications uh that we
can say about
you know a mathematical statement and uh
it's a really powerful tool for proving
things as well we're not going to
quite get to the proving today but i
want us to understand what the objects
are
so let's have a look at what's here and
then see why this bottom row is
incomplete right
start over in the top left seems like a
reasonable place
an implication is a certain kind of
statement right we know what statements
are it's a thing that can be true
or false but not both an implication is
a particular
kind of statement what what's its format
you can actually see it over there on
the right hand side
all implications have kind of two halves
to them right what are the two halves
there's uh you can even see the words
here right
there's some kind of condition that you
start with right
and you say if if this is true
then and then it comes the second half
right then then this must also be true
so
p implies q is kind of our general way
of saying that right
and we have notation that goes with this
which we might as well put just to gain
our familiarity here right so an
implication
is always going to be the form p some
statement
implies q if p then q and you can see a
bunch of them over here right
if n is prime and you can see when they
say the word prime
they me when i say the word prime we're
clearly talking about uh whole numbers
here right i'm not worrying about
uh you know irrational numbers fractions
that kind of thing
if n is prime that implies that the
square root of n
is irrational is that true is that a
true statement
it is right you can think about all the
prime numbers you know uh 2 3 5 7
11 and so on and so on if you take the
square root obviously it's not a square
number because then it wouldn't be
prime anymore right so therefore n is
prime
implies square root of n is irrational
so we've got the p
then q and we might as well say by the
way since uh since you just told me
this is a true statement we're going to
label all of these cells by the way as
to whether true or false that's going to
be important later
now before we get to these other
different examples over here we're going
to use them to explore these categories
on the left
let's think about these other categories
a negation a negation is the
what was our sort of uh colloquial word
for it started with an o
it's the opposite right it's like p
implies q the opposite of that
is that p implies not q the opposite
right
not q and this is the way we wrote it or
you could put that um
that wavy uh sort of line out the front
they both mean the same thing
right so p implies not q what would that
look like for this particular example
we're still considering p being the same
so n is
prime that thing is unchanged and then
i'm considering
is it true that that implies now what
would be
the negation of q the opposite of q
root n is if you're not irrational
you're
rational so let's write that down
there's our not q
the square root of n is rational
okay so let's quickly make a statement
about whether this is true or not
we know that if n is prime not that
we've proved it but we
are happy to be convinced by it that it
implies a square of n's irrational
so what does that tell you about the
negation is it true or false
but it has to be false the whole point
of them being opposite is that if one's
true the other is false
if one's false the other's true so let's
just jot that down
this is false okay
now this is one way to think about you
know the opposite there's another way
you could think about it
which is this converse idea now this
reverses the flow
of the logic so instead of p implying q
the converse would be q implies
p so we could uh we could draw a
backwards arrow if you wanted you could
say the arrow is going to the left
or because you know in english we
normally read from left to right you
could
write the q first q implies
p what would that look like here
well i'm just taking the same p and q
and just writing them in reverse yeah
so in this case i would say q is the
square root of n
is irrational i haven't changed that
statement from that top line
up the top right and then i'm wondering
well does it
imply that n is prime
now just like i have for these two
statements above i'm going to ask the
question
is this true
is the first line square root of n is
irrational
is that sufficient to say is it
guarantee
that n will be prime now i see some
people shaking heads but i'm wondering
and this is really easy if anyone can
prove to me that this is not true
any takers what are you thinking oh we
know the square root of
6 is irrational but 6 is composite
very good did you catch that right what
john's giving us is a we have a name for
this right
it's an example of this not being true
it's a counter-example do you remember
that
we might just quickly jot that down a
counter example would be
n equals 6.
n equals 6. this immediately like i
don't have to do any other fancy logic
it immediately shows that this isn't
always true but that line that implies
line
without any other kind of conditions or
quantifiers
it's saying on you know categorically
this is always the case but it's not we
just showed that it's not
so this is true or false it's false
right
now this is really important because if
you have a look here we know that the
implication
being true means the negation is false
what does it say about the converse
well it doesn't guarantee anything right
in this case
just because the first statement was
true its converse
was false but you'll see in a second as
we can go across the other
columns sometimes it is true so it's
kind of uncertain
all right now i promised a new category
a new idea and that's what you can see
down the bottom here
if you take this idea of negation and
this idea of a conversation you kind of
mash them
together you get a weird i'm going to
tell you what the word is first and then
i'm going to show the notation around it
you get this weird new idea called a
contra
positive weird word
um it looks like a word a german person
made up because they just make up words
by putting other words together right
contra means sort of against
but positive means like they're together
right it's like what does contrapositive
mean
let me show you the notation we'll sort
of translate it for this particular
statement
and then we'll think about why is the
contrapositive interesting at all okay
so here comes the symbols the contra
part of contrapositive
is that we are going to number one
negate
both of the statements that we had up
before so we had p and q before okay so
we're going to negate both of them
so i'm putting two negation signs there
and in addition to that
we are also going to like the converse
we're going to reverse
the statements what's going on here so
i've put two negations
and then i'm going to imply them in this
direction
so if p implies q the contrapositive of
that
is that not q implies
not p hm now you're so far
when you look at this notation you're so
far seeing the contra part of this you
can see it's like
anti-opposite in all kinds of ways but
why is there a positive
there well let's let's do let's
translate this for this particular
example
and maybe you'll see why it actually is
justly named the contrapositive
what's not q we've actually already
written it here
root n is rational i wrote that in this
negation statement right here
okay so sorry i'm going to be a bit
cheap and lazy i'm going to take that
there's not q
okay the contrapositive says that that
implies
not p
what is not p the negation of p
would be since p is n is prime the
negation of that would be n is
now it's sneaky right it's tempting to
say composite
but there are some numbers out there
that are neither composite
nor prime the main example is
one is the main one we think about when
we think about primes we generally only
worry about positive numbers zero of
course is its own basket case of a weird
sort of situation
but one's the important one that is it's
not prime
for weird fun reasons the fundamental
theorem of arithmetic
it's also not composite because it's not
like other factors you can put in there
so even though i'd love to say n is
composite is the opposite that's not the
real negation all i can say is
n is not prime okay
now let's think about why this ends up
being called
the contrapositive this particular p
implies
q is true you guys told me that right at
the start okay
is the contrapositive true or false
is it true or false square root of n is
rational
that means n isn't prime hmm
now i've already heard some early
suggestions as to whether this is true
or false i want you to think about
logically
what this tells you if the square root
of n is rational what can you tell me
about n you can actually tell me quite a
lot about it
square to n is rational
what numbers could n be someone give me
an example
yeah it could be a it has to be a square
number of some kind right like
1 or 4 or 9 or 16 25 etc right
put a square number in there and you'll
get a rational result
now squares none of them are prime once
you go
off past one right i'm not considering
that as a trivial result and n is not
prime anyway because
one we already excluded that right it's
that weirder number
so this is in fact true do you agree
with that
now this is why it's called the contra
positive
what you can see about the implication
of the negation is they're opposite
they're opposite statements but in fact
the implication
and the contrapositive they sit together
in fact they're not just together
they're not just sort of similar
they are in fact equivalent
remember what equivalent means
equivalent means
you might as well be saying the same
thing one is true
if and only if the other one is true
so these are very tightly linked in fact
and this is the main reason why we're
learning about this object right
the reason why this is so useful is
sometimes it's much easier to prove the
contrapositive is true
than the implication and that's great
because if you proved one you have
proved
the other okay so we've got these top
and bottom ones being equivalent